people we just watched the first episode
of moon night uh full disclosure that we
were sent screeners for first four
episodes we might watch the second one
we might watch it that's a big maybe
episode three and four we're gonna wait
till it's actually air because um
apparently they're like not finished or
something and seriously why would we
wait that we can't record a reaction it
doesn't make sense but in the meantime
rejects re-re-enter reacting but what i
want to do really quick is hop in here
and just quickly give our thoughts on
what we thought of the first episode
because it's brilliant it's brilliant i
am not sugar coating that whatsoever
what a setup it really is like fight
club meets indiana jones oscar isaac is
amazing
wow he is so good i love steven grant
already
johnny quick thoughts buddy oh dude i
couldn't agree morgan some great great
camerawork great effects great mood and
tone and also great antagonist i'll say
portrayal right now by ethan hawk as
well i i'm eating it up and i cannot
wait to see more it's right up my alley
coy it feels like greg smallwood art
come to life
i'm really really enjoying the entire
feel of it and i think that loki might
have some competition from my favorite
show it's obviously way too early to
tell but having seen one-sixth of this
if it stays and sticks the landing if
this stays as good as it is and the
sixth episode has me feel resolved this
probably will take out loki i love that
it's so immersive and i also love that
it doesn't feel like you need to have
experienced other marvel content before
i think at some point there is a
threshold of too much tying together
causing negatives instead of just
inherently like oh that's funny easter
egg sometimes you need less of that to
build out your universe this is probably
the biggest world building expansion
since one division it's really special
yeah it's like psychological pure
supernatural i
i really loved it a lot man i don't want
to give too much away just just know
that it's uh for a first episode i'm i'm
insanely hooked into uh everything you
gotta uncover here it's gonna be it's
gonna be great stuff keep a lookout for
a really in-depth review after the
reaction as well obviously you can't
post that reaction until the episode's
out well it wouldn't make sense
reacting yeah
so keep a lookout for that we'll have it
ready for you by the time it comes out
thank you guys for being here subscribe
and click that notification bell swallow
this one on tick tock yay
[Music]